in one minute all that class is gonna
disappear and we have to defend our bank
from these 100 random minecraft players
they are in survival mode
we're in creative mode your swords are
one hit kill watch I'm gonna test it on
a nerd well every time they get in the
bank they get 10 points whoever has the
most points at the end wins $10,000 and
they have 8 minutes to try to get as
much points as they can Hey
[Music]
all right the gates about the drop
protect the bay get ready I'm ready okay
why are you running back I gotta get
these guys come here yeah I'm gonna
target this guy Alex oh oh I see a lot
of signers but uh Oh No
lots of people are score get No Oh Oh I
killed him right before he got it he's
so mad oh this guy thought he was
getting through it I'm gonna stand right
here cuz they all have to pass through
spongebob
more like sponge gone No did I keep
killing this oh shoot I accident liked
it
we lost our last line of defense backed
up no I backed up I'm here I'm here
Oh snipe let's hold a vise
[Applause]
oh boy you don't I'm just yeah and by
just smacking them bro hey what the
person would be Smurfs through Becca
let her through she has be Smurf you're
letting so many people through oh I've
ran into the spotter get over here No
ten grand for you ten grand for you
sorry for you know ten grand it's not
bias no because we don't know who these
people are
I'm a lawn mower look you got through no
nope no ten grand for you oh wait
besmirch everyone besmirch coming
through a lot more time this is target
practice
except for screwing people over you can
live since you're being tamed and you
can live because you have besmirch go
through go I won't harm you pink M boom
round one is over and currently she'll
hex more isn't first with 110 points Wow
they don't even know they're playing for
10 grand yet man I'm gonna go on the
discord announce it now hello can you
guys hear me
yeah the announcement I wanted to make
is whoever has the most points at the
end wins $10,000 this person right here
could literally be fifteen and live in
his mom's basement I don't know but he
is currently on track or she to win
$10,000 as you can see by the scoreboard
a lot of people got through yeah so
we're gonna spice it up let's spawn some
HUS these big rhinoceroses alright let's
watch it wreak havoc look it's already
killed one person so as you can see
these huts are really gonna slow people
down now before I start the second round
I want to spawn an army of these huts
good luck in through this boy oh my god
good luck alright start the timer let's
see how many scored this time since
round two is harder they get 20 points
every time they break into the bank
instead of ten so scoring now is a lot
more important
the gates will open into one go
scores go oh they're getting within us
we're spotting more huts for smiling
more
alright alright we need art army are you
I got this we need Ravagers we need
Ravagers down all right let's see how
many get through let's see I'm gonna get
through all right they're still getting
through but the numbers are definitely
thin oh oh the Huskers stopping them and
now we defend go I think the huts are
making it easier on me because I can't
hit with haha wait stop spawning so many
huh who spawned all these I spawned him
I thought it would stop them nope does
why don't they ask for the Rhinos oh I
actually hit besmirched they're not a
growing wait what they're not attacking
our plate is me forward all right guys
our mobs aren't working so let me try
this I spawned two guests are those
aggro yeah they're it's killing all
right let's fun guys screw it all right
we're doing gas now gas for the wind I
go gasp oh my gosh there's so many
guests everywhere the screams I'm gonna
have nightmares if so many guests oh my
god this is pure chaos there we go
alright I'm gonna just put some in there
spawn - oh my god are the gas actually
killing them yes
No ten grand for you know ten grand for
you Jimmy I found a egg in my minion you
got an Enderman all right should we get
some in German in here I'm gonna go
spawn camp oh my gosh the guests are out
in the open - oh my god hey I found the
guy in first shot should I let him go
through no get him if I hit him this
could cost him $10,000 right here I'm
sorry buddy I'm sorry
boom no ten grand so I throw wither are
you putting a wither out what do you
think I think we should try it I just
want to let us go with a spawn the
little ender mites have an army of rats
it's going somewhere I don't know what
it's going after what are all these
things on the ground you Chris what is
on the floor wait though the ender
dragon just flew away he nope doubt oh
my god the ender dragons gone
we have tons of magma cubes blocking it
there's no way they're getting through
except for that guy sisters you gotta we
gotta cover the sides do we're lagging
out our server I spawned a wither I'm
just gonna spawn a bunch of Withers oh
dude they're marking people oh my god
Oh she'll boi jet iron shell are tied we
could end somebody's career right here
so many people are dying to these magma
cubes they're not making it the magma
cubes were genius well hi there polar
bears there did you put the polar bears
there polar bears look like they're
having fun bro this is insane what is
this I think the lag is causing the time
to slow down so I just go ahead and yeah
I'm just gonna go ahead and end it and
that is the end of round two
currently boy Jedi has 390 points and
she'll hex more has 390 they are tied
for $10,000 so for this next round for
the third and final round
we have buckets of lava and we also have
buckets of water here's the thing
breaking into the bank on round three
gets you 30 points which is a lot that
is a lot that's three times more than
what they got in the first round so use
this lava and water as much as you want
make it as hard as possible on them
start the timer let's do it it's the
third and final round we also have
creeper X I forgot to mention that let's
go let's see does it creep oh my gosh
the creepers the hole they're putting
out water putting it work all right here
we just handlers creating a waterfall
okay oh just slow them down all right
good good idea good eyes good idea good
idea I'm laying creepers everywhere
oh boy Jed I got it Oh No yes look oh
yes the creepers are killed him I'm just
gonna stay here spawning creepers what
Chris that's an interesting place to put
lava oh gosh I mean it's for 30 points
make it as hard as you want boys all
right let's do it oh my gosh Taylor what
its way did you block the front doors
lava Kevin there's only one entrance now
but they can still jump through it I
think it still jump through it oh my
gosh it's a war zone here guys Bourget I
still in the lead no shell hexam it just
took the lead for 50 I'm gonna put lava
right in front of
exit I'm gonna put a bunch of creepers
and spawn there's a secret passage if
you climb up these ladders and you go on
this building right here and then you go
right here you can actually enter the
bank from the top okay what we're gonna
do guys come here to the doors at the
bottom mm-hmm what let's block off these
doors with lava and let's see who's
smart enough to use the secret passage
they might think there's no way in but
there is and the people who figure it
out are the smart ones and they're the
ones that deserve to win ten grand but
we should also put a couple of creeper
oh we got one no this guy is doing it
but no no don't put the creeper so let
him let him get through this guy's stuck
in the swimming animation whoo lots of
people are doing the secret passage what
are you guys doing he doesn't work a lot
of creepers here
no one's getting through these doors
only the people coming from the top
oh here's shell oh yeah he's he knows
100 perfect wait so she'll finally
figured out yeah shell figured it out
he's making it through oh there's
Bourget ID this guy's the one currently
in the lead oh they're knocking him up
no
dude that's so mean oh my goodness
they literally teamed up on Jedi are
yeah it knocked him off do Jedi can't
catch up dude that's so rude look there
there he is day they're saying no
$10,000 whoa John eyes getting up there
he's getting up there he's almost up
he's almost up
Oh Jedi got up boy Jedi got up what has
shell figured it out anyone have eyes on
him shells tied for first but it he
hasn't scored in like three minutes he
probably spent three minutes trying to
go through the lava that's so
unfortunate
all right here here's the thing guys
let's play mind tricks let's clear the
lava on this left passage for yeah let's
do this and let's see how long you take
something notice Chris look no one's
trying it there's a faster path over
here yeah I didn't know any better
Oh shoh hammer go go go show heaven oh
yeah I didn't even eat you I'm trying
I'm making a pathway there's no one tell
no one's taking the path we cleared up
even love me clearly making it Oh spook
fool found it this one this guy right
here just found it these spook fool gets
it do what if spook fool uses this as a
chance to catch up and win because he's
the only one who knows know what I'm
gonna use fireworks to signal look I I'm
launching fireworks let's see if this
gives it away here I'm gonna let's put
down oh there's only 30 seconds left
oh my gosh there's 30 seconds and Jedi's
in the lead Oh Jack just scored Jack
just someone helped Jack hurry all right
boy jenna is gonna win the only person
who can beat up is jack where's jack
tensa hen boy hi hey seven six five four
oh and Jed I just scored oh and the
round is over
oh my gosh he can't hear me but you won
I will graduate him in one second you
jacked your 50 points away from $10,000
check no why hey Jack just don't watch
this video
just please don't watch it Chris please
move in Jedi you just won $10,000
congratulations speechless man doesn't
rule this doesn't really happen on a
daily basis how old are you 16
you were 16 and you just won 10 grand on
minecraft by playing Minecraft what do
you think you're gonna buy with I'm
gonna hopefully buy a new computer and
I'll save the rest we're about in the
video is there anything you want to say
Jedi to the hopefully millions of people
that watch this um subscribe you're
right he's right hit that subscribe
button Thank You Jedi
we'll see you in the next video I'll get
you your 10 grand